Now, it's important to remember
that we're not here to teach you
how to build a weather app.
It's not even to teach you all the Android
APIs that we use to build it.
It's really about retraining your brain
to start thinking like a mobile developer,
which is really important,
because at the end of this course
we're gonna ask you
to build your own final project.
We're expecting you to already be familiar
with object-oriented programming,
and to have experience
with Java or a similar language.
Personally, I got started with Android
after years of Delphi and C# development.
As engineers, we're trained to map our
experiences in one language
or SDK into new ones.
Looking for patterns and shortcuts we can
get up to speed as quickly as possible.
But mobile, and Android in particular,
have some fundamental differences
that mean some of our experience
and intuition will actually make us
worse mobile engineers.
We like to think of Smartphones
as computers that fit into our pockets.
In a way that's true, but they're
computers from the 90s,
like this Powerhouse I was using
nearly 20 years ago.
With limited internet connectivity,
low speed CPUs, and limited RAM,
on top of which, they're all
running on batteries.
As we go through the course,
I'll be returning to each
of these key mobile challenges.
Looking for places where you're
experienced on desktop or server,
or even other mobile platforms
might lead you in the wrong direction.
I will also be back to tell you some
stories from the early days of Android.
Stories that describe how the Android
platform has evolved.
And nowhere is that more
readily apparent than here,
at the Android Lawn sculpture garden.
Join me here, at the very heart
of Android, at the end of this lesson,
to find out how this sculpture garden
of tasty treats,
also tell us the story
of Android's history.
For now, let's get back to building
that weather app.
So, we'll cross to Dan, to take a look
at some mocks.